sur le président ma question s'adresse à
la garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice et à la suite du président sueur
je vais vous parler de votre boussole
voilà une semaine que des révélations
concernant un email de votre ministère
au cabinet du premier ministre plonge le
monde judiciaire et les élus dans le
désarroi et la consternation
ce document destiné à élaborer une
stratégie à adopter pour la suppression
de certains cabinets d'instruction
entend cibler opérer un tri en fonction
des scores obtenus par le parti
présidentiel et selon le couleur
politique des élus des villes concernées
les villes potentiellement visés par
ladite réforme se transforme en effet en
véritable cible électorale
ce procédé est profondément choquant
comment voulez vous justifiez dans
l'organisation territoriale de notre
justice une sanction envers les
territoires qu'ils ne voteraient pas
comme il faut
l'intrusion de considérations
politiciennes dans l'ordre du judiciaire
est un manquement grave à la stricte
séparation des pouvoirs et aux
fondements de la démocratie
tous les services de l'état doivent
naturellement agir dans la partialité
mais s'il ya bien un qui doit être le
plus simple irréprochable de tous c'est
bien évidemment la justice alors madame
la ministre moi je n'ai qu'une seule
question et non pas quatre et elle est
simple j'espère obtenir une réponse
pouvez-vous nous assurer de la mise en
place d'une procédure parfaitement
transparente avec des critères
réellement objectifs dans leur
groupement territorial des pôles de
l'instruction